once you've identified your top few
advantages there are a few frameworks
you can use to outline them we're going
to use a grid to map all your
competitors on one slide and position
you as the leader you're going to create
something like this for your final
project let's start with focusing on two
things that you really excel at these
are your competitive advantages we'll
use these to label the two axes of the
grid and we want you to place your main
competitors here but again you'll be
positioned as the leader right in this
area these competitive advantages can be
price first value or you can write a
specific value to your customer maybe
think of something that your potential
users or investors would be really
really interested in or excited about so
we'll have to name our two axes
accordingly so if it's price it'll be
low price and high price now let's say
our value is innovation we can have high
innovation and low innovation or you can
do something else
so for specific engine Eric let's talk
about this for abarkment we started to
realize that the general market was a
bit crowded so we needed to find a
unique value to differentiate our app
from let's say a dog kennel so we
decided to focus on a niche market and
go the same idea but only for fancy dogs
with the most refined taste we're going
to offer high-end services will only
accept sitters who have nice homes and
nice backyards those sitters must take
the dogs on multiple walks a day and the
sitters must only offer the highest
quality food and care for the dogs for
the more refined abarkment we chose a
grid that includes one axis for quality
let's change that now one axis for
quality so we have high quality and low
quality and we're going to keep the
specific in generic axis so now that we
have our grid we're going to choose
competitors from the product form
category so these are our direct
competitors and we might also find a few
other relevant competitors so we have
the local kennel which is pretty generic
and the quality is not great but
sometimes they're associated with vets
so that's good then we have the dog
house
which is more specific because they only
take dogs but they're not as specific as
we are and the quality is not super
great
they don't really vet their sitters then
we have doggie vacay
which they're pretty good quality but
they're not as specific as we are and
finally we have Rover who also has great
quality but they're more generic than we
are so notice that we're here in the top
right hand quadrant this is the best
place to be and it really sets us apart
from all of our other competitors